présidentielle à sa dauphine
d'ilmaroussef Louis Ignacio Lula da
Silva et le président le plus populaire
du monde c'est ce qu'a dit de lui Barack
Obama
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après deux mandat 8 ans au pouvoir il le
quitte avec un taux d'approbation de
87%. il a 65 ans et la Constitution ne
lui permet pas de briller un troisième
mandat consécutif
[Musique]
cette ancienne ouvrier d'une usine
d'auto de San Paolo devenue syndicaliste
est né dans une très grande pauvreté
dans le nord-est du Brésil il se
présente quatre fois la présidence pour
enfin triompher en 2002
[Musique]
sous sa direction le Brésil connaît des
années dorées l'économie prospère 30
millions de Brésiliens sortent de la
pauvreté grâce à de généreux programme
sociaux et le pays jouit d'un grand
prestige dans le monde
mais sa protéger Dilma Rousseff n'est
pas à la hauteur quand l'économise
détériore elle est destituée par le
Congrès le gouvernement du Parti des
travailleurs se retrouve pris dans un
gigantesque scandale de corruption qui
éclabousse fondateur
accusé de corruption il fait de la
prison et la justice l'empêche de se
présenter aux élections de 2018 contre
jaillir bolsona puis cette même justice
annule sa condamnation à 12 ans de
prison pour vice de forme le Parti des
Travailleurs le PT est discrédité mais
Lula lui rebondit
plus grand politique l'histoire de
Brésil après il a été incarcéré
après son procès a été annulé donc il
revient comme quelqu'un qui
a été
accusé de façon injuste
[Musique]
qui est malgré ce qu'il a
ce qui s'est passé avec les petits les
petits il y a 4 ans était tout le monde
pensait que les petits étaient morts
ressuscite au point qu'il frôle la
victoire au premier tour contre le
président Jaïr bolsonaro
mais les résultats montrent un Brésil
dangereusement polarisé et une extrême
droite plus forte que prévu
les affaires de corruption ont montré
qu'une partie du Brésil ne voudra jamais
rien savoir de Loola et du péter une
autre partie est révoltée par les propos
et les politiques de Jaïr bolsonaro Lula
est en avance dans les sondages mais je
pense que l'avantage qui nous l'a a
c'est pas un avantage qu'on peut dire
bon c'est gagné c'est je pense que
la peut gagner oui il est en avant mais
ça va dépendre les gens vont voter ou
pas à quelques jours du scrutin l'écart
se resserre dans les sondages qui ont
bien du mal à évaluer le rôle que
joueront le vote nul ou blanc et
l'abstention Jean-Michel Leprince
Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]